vraiment un peu dessus fin quand les
familles normales parler d'affaires
plein avec vous vous avez grandi dans le
quartier saint-michel et vous avez déjà
dit que vous êtes devenu le comédien en
quelque sorte pour pour attirer
l'attention
en vieillissant ce que ça change a
changé les brisures c'est tout le temps
alors un peu quand même
ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien la
valorisation que j'ai eu dans les
dernières années ça ça me donne une
grande leçon aussi dans la vie pour être
capable de lieu d'être envieux d'être
jaloux des fois du bonheur des autres de
dire hey sur mon compte
non non oui enfin je suis sincère je
serai d'un long combat au début j'étais
frustré quand je vois que les gens ça ça
m'a dérangé beaucoup de moyens ça m'a
vraiment dérangé ça me fait de la peine
d'être comme ça à pépieux comme qu'on
capable d'être content maintenant pour
les autres c'est ma plus grande fierté
je pense avant vous pouviez pas être
content pour les autres vins des fois il
ya des enfants qui me dit quand j'ai
rencontré le jeu vous vous énervez axa
l'humain j'étais content mais ce à des
préjugés contre les gens que je
connaissais pas où trouver des fois
pourquoi lui ou de moi j'ai du mal à
vous parce que c'est votre chalet c'est
écrit bon vilain vous avez ce double vie
mais on a poussé on l'a tous je suis
persuadé à sion moi je suis très je sais
pas si vertueux mon affaire mais
j'essaie d'être un bon citoyen vraiment
le jeu c'est vraiment des notes comme
quelqu'un de verser de mourir à tout le
monde passe vraiment tout le monde
m'intéresse c'est pas fourni non je
pense cours j'essaye ça m'intéresse tout
le monde quelque chose d'intéressant à
révéler tout ce pack des fois je trouve
immonde sujet recettes ou cacher quelque
chose de drogue de mouvements mais gelé
a été assez longtemps donc j'ai pu goût
des masques adolescence de tiercé dirt
message tâche est compliquée avec moi
même je mets mais pour jeu même époque
est et comment on s'aime angleterre puis
à ceux permettant d'en déplacer
compenser pour yannick taïso
mais si si je fais la famille et moi je
donne mon avis c'est pour écouter les
autres pour pas attendre que les autres
mais quand vous êtes j'ai eu quand même
la chance de mercis pour me donner la
chance d'aller m'exposer auprès de monde
qui pouvait qui aurait pu qui pouvait
m'aider qu'il pouvait me lever en fait
c'est tout ces gens là au petit lait je
te parle c'est beaucoup ces gens là qui
m'ont dit des vocables défaut de la
crise on mérite pas se voiler coûté deux
minutes c'est grâce à ces gens là je
capable de leur rendre la pareille ou le
rendre à quelqu'un d'autre mais c'est
une méchante métaphore parce que vous
jouez un personnage assez violent dans
mon force sur le tout nouveau film qui
prend l affiche encore un parent ce qui
est de l'équipe c'est une histoire post
apocalyptique dans les films newsom gold
la faille vous interprétez justement des
personnages assez violent et des
passages qui sait pas ce que c'est parce
que je le sais mais j'ai la distance
dessus de ces mêmes facile de jouer
quand je vois que c'est mon idée que je
m'en fais passer d'une explication mende
correctement explique seul jeu mais j'ai
besoin que le fait que si j'avais été
trop encore complaisant api en 2010 et
le prochain en ce jeu pour être poli
jouer ce personnage parce que je serai
encore là d'un trop près ça sera un
défouloir et leur défouloir donnerait
trop la frime trop plaisir également de
se voir juste tellement besoin de
s'exprimer quand on n'a pas le goût de
l'écouter
une question sans gauche en plus d'être
comédien vous êtes cordonnier à boozer
fait beaucoup de sport du ski de fond du
hockey comment trouvez-vous l'équilibré
entre la vie professionnelle et la vie
personnelle avec le sport c'est ça fait
partie du cosmos pour vous il faut je
pensais pour la santé mentale ses
excuses je peux pas facile à vivre
la seule fois il me semble dans la vie
moi ce qui me suivait depuis le début
ces chutes bonne foi je veux que les
affaires se règlent bien que le monde je
quelqu'un de profondément pacifique mais
véhicules spécifiques chiffres us mais
je suis ici j'ai beaucoup d'énergie ou
des coûts d'énergie
j'ai bien déprimé le rab long de
l'authie des fois faut qu'on avance un
peu ou très impatient de toute ma table
c'est inédit
si je porte tout à fait à ces mêmes
personnes tout le temps facile donc lui
faut juste une chance mais fois que faut
que je fasse du camp je fais du sport
canin sam braun depuis jusqu'à partie
comme quand j'étais à l'école de théâtre
mais on m'a donné j'allais voir en vo 17
j'étais capable
l'espèce il fallait tirer des 10 litres
à l'exercice de missions de la la la
diction h n'ai joué que neuf ouvriers va
rechercher un pâtissier de course puis
il m'a donné la permission tintin vous
courez aux pâtes le riz puis revient
j'ai commencé à faire ça ça m'a vraiment
sauver la fin de mon école puis il tire
tout a fallu que je passe vraiment il
pas effectivement j'aimerais bien ça
écrit pour garder ma soi
et puis c'est tout un spontanée très
impulsif factice pas facile à vivre
twitter en faisant du sport
une pilule par joe d'autre chose ça vaut
bien bonne course à pied patrick hivon
merci beaucoup